[موسيقى]
من 25 سنه بدات ان انا احول ان انا اصنع
نماذج متخصصه في السكه الحديد او في
عمليات النقل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
احمد محمد محمد ابو الضياء في النقل العام
الشغل بتاعنا بسيط جدا ان احنا بنشتغل
نصنع نماذج متخصصه في السكه الحديد او في
عمليات النقل
هي هوايه من زمان بالونه طفل اول نموذج
صنعته يمكن كان عندي حوالي سبع ثمان سنين
كان نموذج للقاطره فكره ان انا كنت ساكن
قدام السكه الحديد فكنت بشوف الديزلات او
القطارات الجديده اللي كانت وقتها موجوده
فكنت بحب انفذ حاجه شبيهه بها
[موسيقى]
الفكره بتاعتنا ان احنا نستخدم خامات
البيئه الموجوده ما نستخدمش اي خامه من
خامات الماكيت اللي بيتم التصنيع منها زي
النص بيان او الاكليريك احنا بنحاول نشتغل
اللي احنا بجميع الخامات الموجوده
كانت الامكانات المتاحه حاليا يكون
علبه كرتون او صندوق او غطاء او حاجه نعمل
به عجل او عجل لذلك كان متاح ليا فهي كانت
الموضوع بدا من كده كل حاجه مرميه بنلمها
انا بمشي اي حاجه الاقيها بشيلها واعيد
استخدامها تاني انا عمري ما رمينا علبه
تونه مثلا عمرنا ما رمينا علبه شامبو او
غطا علبه ورنيش او اي حاجه
سماط تاريخ سكك حديد مصر باكمله اللي هو
170 سنه او 165 سنه من بدايه دخول اول
قاطره بخاريه دخلت مصر 1851 لاخر قاطره
اللي هي الموجوده حاليا دخلت الخدمه
[موسيقى]
طبعا هو كان بينقصني عمليه التصميم
الهندسي انا درست فتره التصميم الهندسي
فده ده طبعا ان هو عشان الشغل يطلع
بالشكل النهائي اللي احنا بنطلعه بيه
الحمد لله اللي هو في احنا بنعمل حاجات
متحركه وبتشتغل
ميكانيكيا والكترونيا بتشتغل بالريموت او
بتشتغل الميكانيكيا التصميم الهندسي هو
اللي فادنا في كده ان احنا نقدر نخليها
توصل للشكل ده
اما كونت اسره واتزوجت كان زوجتي هي سالي
هي خريجه جميله هي قالت لي ان احنا نحترف
الشغل وان احنا نعمل
صفحا نعرض عليها شغلنا هو من اول ما
جاوزنا طبعا كنت بشوفه وهو بيشتغل وكان في
مكان في البيت فعلا عامله ورشه دي بيشتغل
فيها كنت حابه الشغل معه قوي لغايه ما
ابتديت بقى شويه شويه اساعده في حاجه حاجه
لغايه ما ابتدت اتعلم ما شفتش حد الحاجات
ديت ما شفتهاش غير في المتحف السكه الحديد
الصور اللي كنا بنشوفها زمان او كده لكن
حد بيعملها وبشوفها من الاول للاخر بتتبني
قدامي كانت اول مره السعاده ان الواحد
كمان لما بيشوف قطر شافه في الحقيقه سافر
بيه ليه ذكرى معاه ويشوفه مجسم صغير وكل
تفاصيله بدقه وبالوانه كانت حاجه مختلفه
ومتعب بالنسبه لي هنختار مثلا نوع من
انواع القطرات هنقول مثلا قاتله بخاريه
اللي هو القاطره الحقيقيه اللي كانت
موجوده القاصرات دي بيبقى موجود منها صور
كثيره جدا في الكتالوجات وفي المجالات
القديمه بناخد القاطره احنا بنعمل لها رسم
هندسي اللي هو بنصغرها بنسبه ايه او
هنشتغل بالاسكيل اللي هنشتغل به وبعديها
بنختار الخرده اللي هي هتتناسب مع
الرسم دوت او مع الاسكيل ده بعد تقطيع
الحاجه وتجهيزه بنجمعه مع بعض وبتيجي
الفتره الاخيره المرحله الاخيره اللي هو
الرش بالرش وبين اللي هو التشطيب له وبعد
كده بتبقى بقى دوري انا انتهى في كده
بيبتدي دورهم هما دور سالي مثلا ان هي
اكتر حاجات انا اشتغلت فيها اللي هي
الوابورات الحاجات الاثريه تبان انتيك
اكتر
[موسيقى]